We didn't try.
He gives zero fucks your route though.
Joe Rode to the experience.
We've been doing it.
Podcasts.
Jesus,
Mary and Joseph.
We Ustream is strong.
You're going to hang in there.
I feel this.
Okay.
This is a new ballot.
Hopefully it'll be,
it'll be on a record.
If not,
you'll,
you'll have it here forever.
Okay.
It's called burn me out.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Okay.
Oh Babe.
By God say
Ah,
Yo words.
I books Hanni Hook like summer time.
Okay.
Cookies and all the way through.
I guess a held on to.
I broke my fingers on your flow.
I lost my faith.
Ooh,
though love can feel I did.
Nice.
Ah,
okay.
Oh yeah.
Aw Man.
Say that God knows away.
Ah,
so you rung me.
Oh wait,
no.
Yeah.
Ah,
oh yeah.
Aw Man.
They burn.
Don't feel good.
Ah.
Oh,
you
okay?
I well cause us trouble to
back on you.
Edd.
Oh,
it's
no.
Ah,
okay.
Is
Ah,
okay.
Yeah.
We're a swarm on this planet.
Swarm this.
There's billions of us.
You were like this when you did it.
I was trying to be like,
wonder woman.
I'll try and be like,
I was thinking strong.
Linda Carter,
we're all in this together.
We're all the fucking swarm me,
beehive.
We're a swarm.
Reagan the honey with this,
a lot of us,
I know.
You knew that was coming.
So as the low hanging fruit,
I mean that was obvious.
There is a fucking lot of us there.
Sure is chill.
You know.